welcome to the smite God reveal for
nemesis goddess of revenge
in smite nemesis unleashes her vengeance
on all who oppose her as a physical
melee warrior of arrogance and pride the
Greeks have but one word hubris it is a
crime against gods and men but a crime
many commits with impunity even mighty
Zeus is guilty but when punishment is
due there is one from whom even the god
of thunder shrinks she is nemesis the
red washed blade of divine retribution
recall the tale of narcissus so taken by
his own beauty
proudly his message was flaunted to the
detriment of all until at last he was
led to a pond of crystal hue where his
own reflection in raptured him so long
did he remain to gaze upon this self
image that homer claimed his life
thus does nemesis respond to hubris it
is consequence equal to the crime now
behold the war-torn land beset by the
wrath of wanton gods filling the air
with blood and boasts this battlefield
is stained with hubris unwittingly these
foolish Warriors have summoned their
greatest adversary nemesis has come
we'll foul deeds and gender success no
hoard of wealth held and undeserving
hands no legends told when falsely
earned nemesis will unleash a tide of
retribution punishment for the crime of
hubris is death
nemesis's passage is called scales of
fate nemesis holds the scales of balance
hitting enemies with basic attacks tips
the scales in her favor increasing her
damage while decreasing that of enemies
hit her first ability is called Swift
vengeance nemesis dashes in a line
dealing damage to enemies in her path if
she hits a valid target she may dash
again her second ability is called slice
and dice nemesis swings her blade
hitting in front of her enemies in the
center of her swing take additional
damage and are slowed nemesis's third
ability is called retribution nemesis
activates a temporary shield protecting
her reflecting back a portion of the
damage dealt to her and healing her
based on damage received nemesises
ultimate is called divine judgment
nemesis chooses a single enemy god and
reduces their health and steals a
portion of the protections and moves
speed for a period
in this fight scenario nemesis stumbles
upon an enemy al Quang while in the
jungle initiating with slice and dice
and Swift vengeance nemesis activates
retribution to fearlessly pass through
al quang's tornadoes and take down the
Dragon King of the eastern seas in this
second fight Nemesis heads to the jungle
to aid her teammates in a teamfight
initiating with slice and dice and
activating retribution nemesis delivers
numerous blows as the enemy nemesis
blinks away passing through the nearby
enemy minions with Swift vengeance
nemesis gets a second - to catch up -
and strike down the enemy nemesis in
this final scenario nemesis notices an
enemy tear and al playing stalking her
allied Zeus initiating with slice and
dice and Swift vengeance nemesis takes
down al Quang with standing tears
powerful even emesis takes down the
lawgiver with a final slice and dice
nemesis reflects devastating damage upon
all who wronged her starting her off
with slice and dice can help nemesis
clear minion waves
additionally the slow it applies can
give her the upper hand against enemy
God's next picking up retribution can
help nemesis stay longer in fights with
the healing and damage reflect potential
from there the priority shift to divine
judgment
slice and dice retribution Swift
vengeance
Athena returns to the battlefield with
the brand-new red star skin bundled with
her new skin is also the exclusive
Olympian Athena skin available only for
a limited time
thanks for watching the smite God reveal
for nemesis goddess of revenge